[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland ich bin Tony haer und ich
bin Mirko Kim mir sag mal was ist
eigentlich dein liebstes fest na ich
weiß genau was du hören willst aber so
leicht Tony so leicht ma ich Dir nicht
mein Lieblingsfest ist
Weihnachten okay okay du hast mich
ertappt ich probiere es anders was ist
dein Lieblingsfest das immer in der
ersten Nacht vom 31 oktober auf den 1
november gefeiert wird bei dem Kinder
von Tür zu Tür gehen und nach
Süßigkeiten Fragen und bei dem Kürbisse
eine ganz große Rolle Spiel ja ja ja ja
schon gut ich weiß schon du meinst
Halloween yes richtige Antwort 100
Punkte und jetzt bitte einmal raushauen
was gefällt dir an Halloween besonders
gut du bist schon eine ehrliche Antwort
oder ja
natürlich gar
nichts du meinst natürlich dass es schön
gruselig ist richtig ja ich meine so so
richtig gruselig ist es ja gar nicht und
wenn es dann doch richtig gruselig ist
ja dann ist es auch nicht mehr schön so
wie Halloween 1974 in Deer Park Texas
meinst du das genau so wie Halloween
1974 in Deer Park Texas nämlich richtig
Gruß
und gar nicht schön wir erzählen heute
die Geschichte vom Candyman auch bekannt
als the man who killed Halloween
wahrscheinlich habt ihr alle schon mal
Geschichten über Rasierklingen oder
Rattengift gehört die fiese Erwachsene
in Süßigkeiten versteckt haben um sie
Kindern zu geben die so unvorsichtig
waren an ihrer Tür zu klingeln und trick
or tre zu fordern brauchen wir gar nicht
lang drumhum reden das meiste davon sind
myen aber okay DAAB gab es diesen Typen
einen kalifornischen Zahnarzt der 1959
Süßigkeiten mit Abführmittel präparierte
üble Geschichte aber doch eine andere
Nummer als tödliche Gifte oder
rasierkling 30 Kinder wurden krank und
man sollte nicht vergessen dass das
nicht nur ein wirklich fieser Scherz war
sondern auch gefährlich hätte werden
können ein weiterer gut belegter Fall
stammt aus dem Jahr
1964 damals gab eine alte Dame in Long
Island an Kinder die sie für zu alt
hielt um nach Süßigkeiten zu fragen ganz
besondere Päckchen heraus diese
enthielten Stahlwolle hundeknabbereien
und
Ameisengift also erstmal wann ist man
denn zu alt für Süßigkeiten aber
abgesehen davon wirklich fiese Nummer
allerdings hatte sie das Gift klar mit
dem Wort Gift gekennzeichnet keins der
Kinder kam auf die Idee das Zeug auch zu
essen zu alt ist man für Süßigkeiten
wenn die Hose
spannt in den folgenden Jahrzehnten gab
es hunderte Berichte über vergiftete
Süßigkeiten oder die berühmten
Rasierklingen oder Nägel in Äpfeln und
Schokoriegeln kein einziger davon konnte
bestätigt werden sehr oft hatten Kinder
selbst ihre Süßigkeiten so präpariert
und es dann gemeldet um andere zu
erschrecken um auf sich aufmerksam zu
machen oder einfach weil es eine so gute
Story war und diese stories en sich wie
in Lauffeuer sie ging so viral wie es im
analogen Zeitalter eben möglich war ob
sie stimmten das war ebenfalls
zweitrangig wenn überhaupt an Halloween
1990 starb die siebenjährige Ariel Catz
in Santa Monica nachdem sie in der
Nachbarschaft Süßigkeiten eingesammelt
hatte die Polizei reagierte sofort sie
riegelte ein ganzes Stadtviertel ab gab
Warnungen heraus und ging von Tür zu Tür
um Eltern zu warnen und Hinweise auf
Gift zu finden später stellte sich
heraus dass das kleine Mädchen an einem
angeborenen Herzfehler gestorben ist
aber da war die Geschichte von der
vergifteten siebenjährigen schon längst
in aller Munde richtig tragisch war das
Schicksal des fünfjährigen Kevin Toon
der kurz nach Halloween 1970 ins Koma
fiel und vier Tage später starb eine
Untersuchung fand Heroin auf sein
halloweenüßigkeiten die Medien die
drehten durch hier war der Beweis böse
Menschen töteten an Halloween unsere
Kinder der abschließende Polizeibericht
bekam dann nicht ganz so viel
Aufmerksamkeit die wahre Geschichte ein
Onkel des kleinen Kevin war
Drogenabhängig als der Junge bei ihm zu
Besuch war fand er das offenbar nicht
besonders sichere Drogenversteck und
vergiftete sich selbst aber wie ist das
Heroin auf die halloweenüßigkeiten
gekommen das war die Familie selbst um
den Onkel zu schützen präparierten sie
die trick or treat Beute und die Medien
und anfangs auch die Polizei waren nur
allzu bereit die Story von einem Fremden
der vorsätzlich ein Kind mit Heroin
vergiftet hatte zu glauben also alles
nur Fake gibt es keine halloweenmorde
und keine vergifteten Süßigkeiten na ja
also wir würden hier nicht drüber reden
wenn das alles nur ein Spaß
wäre Halloween
1974 eine regnerische Nacht in Deer Park
Texas was natürlich kein Kind davon
abhält um die Häuser zu ziehen zu
klingeln andere zu erschrecken sich
erschrecken zu lassen und Süßigkeiten
abzugreifen auch der achtjährige Timothy
O'Brien und seine fünfjährige Schwester
Elizabeth sind zusammen mit ihrem Vater
Ronald Clark O'Brien unterwegs ihr
Nachbar Jim Bates und sein kleiner Sohn
schließen sich der Gruppe an es läuft
gut bis sie an ein dunkles Haus kommen
offensichtlich ist niemand zu Hause aber
die Kinder wollen ihr Glück versuchen
und klopfen und klingeln als niemand
öffnet rennen sie davon auf zum nächsten
Haus als Vater Ronald sie wieder einholt
hat er gute Nachrichten es war doch
jemand da erzählt er und obwohl die
Kinder schon weg waren hat er eben ein
paar pixisticks
[Musik]
mitgegeben pixys Sticks das sind so
bunte längliche Papiertütchen die sehen
bisschen aus wie ein langer Strohhalm
und da drin ist gefärbter aromatisierter
Zucker Ronald verteilt die Beute an die
Kinder es bleibt sogar noch so ein
zuckerröchen für ein anderes Kind übrig
dass sie auf dem Heimweg treffen und das
Ronald aus der Kirche kennt als die obri
zu Hause ankommen darf sich Timothy
etwas von den erbeuteten Süßigkeiten
aussuchen er wählt das Pixi Sticks
Röhrchen sein Vater muss ihm helfen den
Zucker herauszubekommen weil der in dem
Papier fest steckt dann beschwert sich
Timothy dass das Pulver bitter schmeckt
sein Vater holt ihm ein
Erfrischungsgetränk um es herunterz
spülen und den Geschmack los zu werden
kurz danach beginnen die Bauchschmerzen
Timothy rennt ins Bad erbricht sich
verfällt in Krämpfe sein Vater ruft den
Notarzt hält den Jungen im Arm und merkt
plötzlich wie der kleine Schlaf wird
keine Stunde später ist Timothy O'Brien
tot der Staatsanwalt Mike hinten hat in
dieser Nacht Dienst in der
Polizeiinspektion von Harris County als
er einen Anruf der Polizei in padina
erhält die ih mitteilt dass ein Kind
gestorben sei reagiert er sofort er ruft
einen Gerichtsmediziner an und bittet um
schnellen Rat wonach hat der Atem des
Kindes gerochen fragt er hinten ruft im
leichens Schauhaus an und gibt die Frage
weiter da kommt Mandelgeruch aus dem
Mund des Kindes lautet die Anwort als
sich henten erneut an den
Gerichtsmediziner wendet ist der sich
sicher das ist
[Musik]
Zan das ist er der wahr gewordene
Halloween Albtraum mit zyanit versetzte
Süßigkeiten das ist echter Horror in
einer Nacht in der man sich Zar gruselig
anzieht aber sich nichtklichchten will
eine spätere Untersuchung wird ergeben
dass der kleine Timothy genug Gift
geschluckt hat um zwei oder drei
Erwachsene zu töten sofort schwärmen
Polizeibeamte in die Halloween Nacht aus
um die anderen Pixi Sticks zu bergen
wenn man bedenkt wie ungehemmt viele
Kinder bei solchen Gelegenheiten naschen
grenzt es fast an ein Wunder aber die
anderen Tütchen sind noch voll und
ungeöffnet aber es ist eine verdammt
knappe Sache einer der Jungen liegt
schlafend im Bett den Pixie Stick in der
Hand er wollte ihn essen hat ihn aber
nicht aufbekommen und ist darüber
eingeschlafen moment mal K nicht
aufbekommen also normalerweise ist das
auch für Kleinkinder kein Problem so ein
Ding aufzukriegen ja normalerweise schon
aber dieser Pixis Stick der ist nicht
original verschlossen sondern
zugetackert also eindeutig manipuliert
doch der Täter war etwas Z gründlich und
das hat das Leben des Kindes gerettet
der kleine Timothy bleibt das einzige
tragische Opfer des Candyman des echten
Halloween
Killers der Candyman muss ja eigentlich
schnell zu schnappen sein das ist
nämlich genau die Sache die ich immer so
super unglaubwürdig an diesen
vergiftungsgeschichten finde mal ehrlich
wer ist so blöd chuldigung dass ich so
deutlich sage aber aus seinem eigenen
Haus heraus vergiftete Süßigkeiten zu
verteilen
also noch leichter kann man sich ja
nicht schnappen lassen oder ja es sei
denn aber erzählen wir lieber erstmal
weiter Ronald Clark O'Brien führt die
Polizei zu jenem Haus das in der
Halloween Nacht in dunkel getaucht war
er sagt er habe nicht genau erkennen
können wer ihm die Süßigkeiten gegeben
habe alles dunkel wie gesagt und ihr sei
ja auch schon auf dem Sprung gewesen um
seinen Kindern hinterher zu rennen und
na ja eigentlich habe er nur einen stark
beharten Arm gesehen hm ich finde ja
übertriebenes Misstrauen nicht richtig
aber ich würde mir nichts in den Mund
stecken was mir ein behaarter Arm aus
einem stockdunklen Haus reicht und ganz
bestimmt würde ich es nicht meinen
Kindern geben also wenn ich welche hätte
ja das könnte man so unterschreiben
jedenfalls Timothys Vater identifiziert
das Haus doch als Polizist an die Tür
hämern öffnet niemand natürlich ist der
Besitzer schnell ermittelt ein fluglotze
am William Hobby PE Airport in Houston
kurz darauf wird er auf seiner
Arbeitsstelle vor den Augen seiner
Kollegen verhaftet schneller Erfolg der
leider keiner ist denn der Mann hat ein
Alibi tja besser gesagt er hat ungefähr
200 Alibis so viele Leute können nämlich
bezeugen dass er in der Halloween Nacht
gearbeitet hat nur seine Frau und seine
Tochter zu Hause gewesen sie haben früh
das Licht ausgemacht sind schlafen
gegangen und haben nicht mehr auf
Klopfen reagiert weil ihnen die
Süßigkeiten ausgegangen waren Mutter und
Tochter also da fragt man sich natürlich
sofort wem von den beiden bitte der
stark behaarte Arm gehört haben soll
oder ob noch jemand mit dem Haus war
oder ob vielleicht alles ganz anders war
und das scheint plötzlich gar nicht mehr
so abwegig als ein Versicherungs
Unternehmen sich bei der Polizei meldet
es stellt sich heraus dass Ronald
O'Brien mehrere
Lebensversicherungen auf seinen Sohn und
seine Tochter abgeschlossen hat die
letzte erst einen Monat vor Halloween
und am Tag danach gegen 9 Uhr am Morgen
nach Halloween gut 12 Stunden nach dem
Tod seines Sohnes da rief er bei der
Versicherung an um das Geld
einzufdern und jetzt klopft die Polizei
wieder an eine Haustür an die von Ronald
Bran dem trauernden Vater dem nach dem
Tod seines Sohnes nichts besseres
einfällt als so schnell wie möglich die
Versicherung zu kassieren sie
durchsuchen das Haus und finden eine
Schere an der Plastikreste kleben wie
man sie auch an den vergifteten
Süßigkeiten gefunden hat Ronald O'Brien
wird verhaftet und der Verdacht gegen
ihn wird immer stärker Zeugen erinnern
sich dass er in einem Volkshochschulkurs
seltsame Fragen stellte unter anderem
was ist tödlicher zankali oder ein
anderes Gift ein Mitarbeiter eines
Chemieunternehmens erinnert sich an
einen Mann dessen Beschreibung auf
Ronald O'Brien passt und der wohl
versucht hat bei ihm zyanit zu kaufen
und nicht zuletzt ist da die Tatsache
dass O'Brien hoffnungslos verschuldet
ist und das Geld aus den
Versicherungspolicen verdammt dringend
braucht am 5 mai
1975 beginnt in Houston der Prozess
gegen Ronald O'Brien
er ist angeklagt wegen Mordes an seinem
Sohn und vierfachen versuchten Mordes er
habe nicht nur versucht seine eigenen
Kinder umzubringen sondern auch die
Kinder anderer Familien nur um von sich
als Täter abzulenken zahlreiche Zeugen
treten auf sie sprechen von einem
merkwürdigen Verhalten auf der
Beerdigung seines Sohnes als ihm die
Aussicht auf einen Urlaub den er von dem
Geld der Versicherung bezahlen wollte
wichtiger zu sein schien als sein
verstorbenes Kind
mehrere bekannte berichten dass er in
den Wochen vor Halloween immer wieder
ein merkwürdiges Interesse an zyanit
gezeigt hatte und seine Frau gibt an
dass sich der kleine Timothy den Pixie
Stick keineswegs selbst ausgesucht hat
sondern dass sein Vater ihn ihm
regelrecht aufgedrängt habe Ronald
O'Brien streitet alle Vorwürfe ab die
Verteidigung stützt sich ganz auf die
allseits bekannten aber völlig
unbegründeten Geschichten von verrückten
Giftmischer die an Halloween wahllos
mgen ein solcher müsse sich in das Haus
des fluglotzen geschlichen haben um
seine finstere Tat zu begehen die
Schauergeschichten nutzen O'Brien
überhaupt gar nichts am 3 juni 1975
befindet ihn die Jury nach kurzer
Beratung für schuldig er wird zum Tode
verurteilt am 31 März stirbt Ronald
O'Brien durch Gift das ihm von
Justizbeamten injiziert
wird MKO ich muss sagen ich habe mich
vorher schon kurz gewundert als wir
drüber gesprochen haben dass sie an
diesem dunklen Haus bei dem niemand
aufmacht warten und die Kinder gehen vor
und er bleibt da noch ein bisschen
länger stehen bis ihm jemand Süßigkeiten
darausreicht das fand ich ehrlich gesagt
schon bisschen off also seltsam weil ich
wird doch meine Kinder dann nicht
Vorrennen lassen und bleibt bei dem Haus
von dem ich ausgehe dass da niemand da
ist noch weiter stehen
oder t ich denke Kinder sind natürlich
auch bisschen ahnungslos ne die vermuten
ja auch nichts Böses in dieser
Geschichte schon gar nicht wenn die
Eltern mit dabei sind oder der Vater mit
dabei ist ja das finde ich auch ganz
krass also das muss ich sagen erstmal
furchtbar dass er sein eigenes Kind
sozusagen opfert um an Geld zu kommen
aber dann eben auch noch diese andere
Ebene das Vertrauen auszunutzen seine
eigenen Kinder man erwartet ja nicht
dass die eigenen Eltern die dich ja
eigentlich beschützen mit ihrem Leben
die aber deins nehmen davon also damit
rechnest du ja nicht als Kind auch erst
schon gar nicht dass ja irgendjemand was
Böses will und ich finde ganz furchtbar
dass ja ganz ganz ganz vielen Kindern
und auch seiner eigenen Familie so ein
schönes Fest was eigentlich zelebriert
wird was Freude bringen soll was Spaß
machen soll wirklich für immer versaut
hat für die betroffenen Familien wird
Halloween natürlich für immer und ewig
verdorben sein das ist ja nur absolut
verständlich für den Rest der Welt ja
geht es so weiter wie bisher dafür
vergessen wir Menschen einfach viel zu
schnell was an schlimmen Dingen in der
Welt passiert ähm und
bei alldem denke ich dass auch
hauptsächlich so die Eltern die
Bedenkenträger sind die sich dann mit
diesen horror stories beschäftigen und
die Kinder nach wie vor sehr unbedarf
daran gehen völlig klar und
normalerweise wenn die Kinder sich in
der bekannten Nachbarschaft bewegen du
kennst deine Nachbarn und lässt die
jetzt auch nicht durch die ganze Stadt
ziehen dann sollte da auch an sich
nichts passieren ausgeschlossen ist nie
etwas ja und so so ein gewisses Risiko
gibt's immer also das bringt einfach das
Leben mit sich auch wenn es eine
wirklich tragische Geschichte ist und
das mit Sicherheit niemand so erwartet
hätte aber er hat halt dieses Event
ausgenutzt um seine furchtbare Tat
umzusetzen weil er dachte er kommt damit
davon aber so war es ja zum Glück nicht
ja so also von daher würde ich jetzt
nicht sagen dass Halloween
ein Fest mit großem Gefahrenpotential
ist das sicherlich nicht höchstens für
die für die Zähne ja für Karies dann
wieder viel mehr Besuche bei dem beim
Zahnarzt anstehen genau da da hast du
absolut
Recht also man auch wenn diese
Geschichte natürlich sehr grausam ist
ist dieses Fazit was wir hier gerade
ziehen so ganz kleines minimales
Augenzwinkern und damit sind wir am Ende
der heutigen Episode angekommen
wir danken Euch ganz herzlich dass ihr
wieder mit dabei wart und freuen uns
wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal
einschaltet eure Tony und euer Mirko bei
der Recherche haben wir Artikel von
cbc.com Slate we und der
englischsprachigen Wikipedia sowie eine
Episode the Halloween poisoner des
Podcasts cautionary Tales with Tim
harford
verwendet dir hat diese Folge von T
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
einfach nicht genug dann hör jetzt in
unsere weiteren Folgen rein hier warten
mehr als 200 spannende Fälle auf dich
wie das Verschwinden von rebecer Rusch
der Prozess gegen OJ Simpson oder die
Entführung von ursela Hermann wir hören
uns bei Tat Deutschland